good morning John it is Friday I've been
thinking about making this video and not
doing it for years for three reasons one
I work too hard it's a problem content
like this tends to assume that
everybody's gonna want to have whatever
the person making the content has and
like I have a fine life but there are
lots of other great lives out there too
I am extremely lucky one of the keys to
productivity is having financial and
mental and social stability and I have
all those things I just lucked into it 3
my secret to productivity I'm not
ashamed of it I'm a little ashamed of it
here it is 80% everything creative I do
I do my best to get it 80% of the way to
as good as I can make it and go no
further
I just don't try to get it to a hundred
percent in every creative project we
have in our minds and in reality a place
where it can get to where we will think
it is the best it looks like this and we
can keep pushing and tweaking until we
get it right into the center there and
that seems like worthwhile get it as
good as you can get it but this is a lie
in four different ways one no one knows
what best is best is subjective it's one
way in your head but it's different in
every person who's going to consume the
thing that you make and so it doesn't
look like this it looks like this - not
only are there different bests inside of
everyone's heads there are different
categories of best like I want my videos
to do multiple different things and
sometimes if I want to do better at one
goal I'm gonna have to pull away from
another of my goal 3 even if there are
actually hard outlines to these things
I'm never gonna be able to see it like
that's the future that's far away I
won't know until I get there the whole
world is just me with my glasses off I
can't see any and for best is always
changing people's opinions and ideas are
always changing and so are mine they're
trying to get a hundred percent to the
best that I can do which is far away
from perfect is even that an impossible
idea saying you can't increase your odds
of getting into the bull's eye yes you
can that's what the 80 percent is about
but I am saying you'll never really know
where you're gonna hit until you
actually throw the dart and if you spend
a ton of time thinking about how you're
gonna throw the dart and you never throw
it you might be doing a whole lot of
work that isn't actually helping so when
I get to 80 percent
I throw the darkest I know that perfect
doesn't exist I know the last 20% of
getting to what I think is best is gonna
be like 90% of the word I know that 90%
of what I'm gonna learn I'm gonna learn
doing that first 80% and releasing the
thing and having it be out in the world
for me those final tweaks I'm not
learning anything I'm just scared and
maybe I am making it better but also
maybe I'm not now stopping at 80% is
hard especially when you're hundred
percent isn't that good yet cuz you're
new to whatever thing you're doing and
that's even harder when you have that
one thing that cannot be taught good
taste because you know how bad your
thing is but worse than that and this is
sort of a separate tip you are gonna
know the thing you create better than
anyone else will ever know you're gonna
know all of its imperfections all of its
issues all of the things that it could
have been but it isn't so you're gonna
see that flawed picture of the thing
that you make whereas when you look at
something someone else made you won't
see those things so your things are
always going to look worse than other
people's things so in my mind getting it
done is success getting it perfect is
not especially because perfect doesn't
exist this is my secret of productivity
not just because it helps me do a bunch
of stuff but because it helps me learn a
bunch of stuff learn how to do new
things and get more data points as to
what's working and what people like and
what I like do it and as I get to 80% of
the best that I can do over and over
again really fast suddenly my new 80% is
way better than my old hundred percent
effort could have been John I'll see you
on Tuesday no I'll see you tonight
also our Halloween show in San Francisco
still has tickets available we're having
a Halloween costume contest you know
it's not required but I am looking
forward to seeing what people put
together